all right jamal we'll go ahead and
get started here we'll open up for
questions and we'll start with mike
singer mike go ahead
jamal um from from the time of
wednesday's
meeting uh up until uh obviously now
have you had a sense are you able to
take yourself out of the moment
and recognize that you are a part of a
historical moment has that have you been
able to reflect and
do you realize that i realize that
um but i'm not trying to take myself out
of the moment
um the black lives matter
is uh i want to say right but you know
it's just freedom
um and that's that's the one we got to
live in that you know
black lives really do matter and um
it's a lot of it's really emotional for
these players to go out there and play
while
the stuff around the world is still
happening all the injustice is still
happening
um and that's where that's why i wear
freedom on my back because
it doesn't matter where you're from um
you know
lives matter and uh you know it's time
to see what's going on
even could come from kansas to see
what's going on because i've been a part
of it it's happened to me having me and
my dad
numerous occasions and some has got to
stop
jamal what did you want people to get
from you setting those shoes on
your stool for two minutes or so before
you started this interview what was your
thought process there
i just wanted you guys to resonate i
just wanted to resonate you guys um
anybody else watching how long was that
two minutes one one person on this who
had a knee on their neck for eight and
we just gotta think about that i guess
it doesn't take me a 23-year-old to
recognize that that's not right that
should be
in everybody's mind um if you don't see
it that way then there's a problem with
you
and uh i just want to let that sit and
uh
you know that was only two minutes
whatever however long you guys can go
back and time it but
i was only a quarter of the time that
somebody had a knee on their neck
um until the life made away
he was a father and a son and
a brother and you know it's
it's tough when you really let us in
your mind and
replay it over and over ahead so